only easy just went backstage for  opening night at Celine Dion's courage  world tour here at payback and how dear  in the audience not  see everyone turned up it's getting good  when you call only it's so positive  [Music]  I can't wings to fly I'll feel that  humble I yeah yeah yeah  can we just point out how amazing Celine  looks 51 rocking a new blonde du and  this sequin dress showing off her legs  it's amazing so we knew crushed it  crashed it I felt that the crowd carried  me Celine started her day with a massage  and admits that the night was kind of  bittersweet because her three sons  stayed home in Las Vegas  did your FaceTime them I called him  before the show they did they had a  message for me so I had my three  children wishing me a lot of courage and  he said I know it's gonna go well mom  and it's not easy but you've been there  before  yeah we love you we miss you and I came  to see them  [Applause]  [Music]